[موسيقى]
هزرنا بعد ثلاث ايام تقريبا من الحرب انه
منطقه الرمال مربع كامل بده ين نقصف
فطلعنا كلنا من المربع وما حدش كان عارف
وين يتوجه يعني اضطرينا نطلع على الشفا
بعدين قالوا لازم غزه كلها تخلي على
الجنوب احنا قلنا خلص يعني ما ضلش كلامي
يعني ما في مكان
[موسيقى]
تروحه الناس بصوا
الشجر هذا المنظر ذكرنا بال كلام اهالينا
واجدادنا بال 48 وكيف نزحوا وكيف طلعوا من
اراضيهم بالضبط اللي كنا نشوفه
بالتلفزيونات والتغريب وهذا كله شفناه بام
اعينا فاضطر طلعنا هنا عودنا اجينا على ال
المكان هذا
و زي ما انت شايف يعني قعدونا في الاخر
بخيم زي هيك هيك في ناس على الرصيف في ناس
بالشارع
وبتعرف يعني خيمه ايش بدها تحمي ل حاميا
من برد الشتاء ولا من حر الصيف بالمدقه
اللي معك دقه انت اي بتعملوا قاعدين بنشد
في الخيمه عشان
الشتاء وزي ما انت شايف ما في ميه ولا في
كهرباء ولا في حتى نت ولا جوال كان
الارسال كمان طافي كثير ما في حتى اللي
بصير في غزه واللي بصير في بيوتنا واللي
بصير ما بنعرف اي شيء عن العالم الخارجي
منعزلين يعتبر منعزلين تماما يعني حتى
اخبار تعرف اخبار ما فيش اخت استشهدت
بجوزها باولادها 25 نفر لليوم بنتها
واولادها تحت
الانقاض ما فيش ميه كل ما كنت اعمل شغله
اغسل او اطبخ على نار ويجمعوا حطب كنت
اتذكر كلام اهالينا انه كيف هاجروا كيف
عملوا كيف كانوا
عاشين كنت استغرب كيف انتم عايشين بخيمه
لدرجه انه انا يعني خلص يعني صرت عايشه
بخيمه وشفت
الشي بعيني يعني زي ما كانوا يقولوا نا
عايشين بخيم وكانوا كل عيلتين وثلاثه فعلا
احنا حاليا كل عيلتين ثلاثه بخيمه واحده
بنضطر ناخذ دور في ميه منابع هناك فبن طر
كل يوم ناخذ دور ولما يصل الدور احيانا
خلص يعني بتكون خلصت ما في مش بالسهل تترك
ارضك ولا بالسهل تترك بيتك ولا بالهل انه
انت تهجر على سينا وعلى اي بلد ثانيه شوف
انت هذه ارضك يعني اللي انت نشات وتربيت
وكبرت فيها صعب انك تنساها مش
بالساهل مش بالساهل انه انت تنسى ارك انا
عمال بقول امتى ارجع على بيتي حتى لو مدمر
يعني خيمتي هذا بدي احطها قبال البيت
واقعد عنده لحد ما الله يفرجها وابنيه ما
في حدا بيترك وطن وبيطلع على شان مخطط
دنيء مخطط اسرائيل الكبرى اللي بسموه
واحنا وين احنا شعب بلا ارض زي ما حكموا
لارض بلا شعب لا ولا مره هم اللي لازم
يطلع هم اللي لازم يتهجموا مش احنا هجرته
48 و67 ظلت هجر كمان 2023
بكفي حواسي نفسي واعتبر انه هي مش هجره
يعني حاقول انه انا لسه في بلدي انه انا
لسه بفلسطين انه انا لسه بغزه بس انا تحت
القصف اتهجر على سينا ولا مره لا بدي اموت
بارضي ساعتها ولا بدي اطلع على
سي ان شاء الله ما بنتجر وان شاء الله
بنرجع بنعمر من اول وجديد هم يهدموا واحنا
بنعمر لما يكون عندي عماره مثلا وعندي
طابع وعندي شقه وفي الاخر اجي في خيمه
معناته هذا صمود لما انا اقعد الف دور على
ميه معناته هذا صمود لما انا اقعد 10 ايام
من غير خبز ومن غير اكل واكل اقل شيء اللي
بس اقضي جوعي هذا اسمه صمود صمود ولا مش
صمود لما اولاد اختي يموتوا ما ما اودعهم
واختي تستشهد ما اودعها ولا اخذ عز هذا
صمود وزي زي ناس كثير غزه طول عمرها
صامده كلهم صامدين واحنا صامدين حنضل
صامدين باذن
الله تبكي على وطن باكمله على وجع ل
الحياه وللدنيا ولا الايام بتخليك تنسى
هذا الوجع ولا عمرك كله ولا عمرين جنب
عمرك بخليك تنسى هذا
[موسيقى]
الوجع
ja